deux modèles face à ce professeur 40
élèves de seconde
objectif commun passer en 1ère s une
carrière scientifique par la suite j'ai
comme projet professionnel
des recharges et comme là
en 1re s en fait si la plus probable
donc c'est ça que j'ai citées par un
médecin le rêve de beaucoup d'entre eux
mais la case redoutable c'est la
première année commune aux études de
santé le paces des années de labeur des
tonnes de notions à connaître dès la
seconde ils y sont préparés à trois ans
du bac ils sont motivés parfois distrait
un peu bavard al'inverse de ses élèves
de terminale s qu'est ce qu'une cellule
procaryotes
qui peut me répondre oui
pour eux le concours au passé c'est
après le bac
ils connaissent les sanctions seules 15%
réussiront soit à peine 10 sur 120
élèves
florence elle veut devenir
neurochirurgienne c'est un match plein
d'avenir
il y a énormément de découverte c'est au
fur et à mesure en avance on apprend du
port tandis capacités
c'est la première émission comme les
autres ils ont fait une croix sur deux
jours de vacances pour réviser les
notions de s'exercer au concours une
formule sur mesure mise en place cette
année ils ont une volonté de travail un
rythme de travail qui est énorme et en
fait c'est ça qu'on essaie de leur
inculquer après va surpasser ce rythme
de travail cette volonté cette rigueur
cette méthodologie et les connaissances
qui vont avec l'univers scientifique
impitoyable séduit de plus en plus la
jeune génération
fort heureusement ils ont tous un plan b